hi everybody
uh welcome back today uh i am sam
uh from python basics and we'll be doing
a
another two hour live stream today
on uh free code camp here
and the regular the way the agenda
usually works
is um it's about two hours
uh don't see anything happening today
was not feeling too hot last week
so but we are gonna finish up uh some
dictionary stuff
because that was requested and that is
very very important to me um and then i
think
there were a couple we were talking
about formatting
and maybe we'll look just real quick at
formatting some numbers and then we're
going to jump into scope
and the reason why i like scope so much
is really lays out
how python looks at variables
and scope is just basically layer of
priority of where it's pulling from
so and then then we'll look at
nested functions and then those are just
a half a step
a half measure that gets us to
decorators and
if we have time very cool use
of nested functions and um
yeah it'll take us a while to get to
some really really case
scenarios of decorators but i will show
you how they use
but the the the one today
uh if we get to and i'm super excited
about it is the monty hall example so
all right let's just get into it is
everybody here everybody ready
yes and i had completely forgotten this
so i had gotten some feedback
that maybe there was glare and i know uh
i've seen this
a lot of times that people like the
darker so
what does everybody think about the dark
background is it easier to see
because i had the red is a little hard
all right all right let's go
cool we're glad to have everybody here
so let's just get into it
so let's finish up dictionaries so we
can get on to our new stuff
all right so what i really want to look
at to wrap up dictionaries
is the reason why they're very powerful
is
one of the awesome examples is if we
were to make a link
and a um basically
a building block of association so let's
just look at the alphabet
real real fast and then
tie these in so from oh
we don't need this let's comment this
out
but also one thing i just uh a little
crash course reminder about the
dictionary
first you have to initiate initialize it
and then
link a value to the key all right
don't need this anymore i hope everybody
has had a good week
uh i am glad to be back so from string
uh import as key
lowercase as lower
so all right if you are unaware of this
module
built-in module and
basically what we're doing here is we're
building uh it's one of the ones that i
like to do
for a really encryption and decryption
um
pretty cool building block of uh
messages
but for i n range
when lower
then key
all right so what i'm doing is i'm going
through this
reason why i'm using the range len
function is so i'm going through
so i don't have to go and wrap an
enumerate object
wrap it up so i can just go through here
and then we're going to look at counting
with a
all right then run this
then called key so oops
that is not what i wanted to do what did
i leave out
ah there we go
key so for
i and key print
so what i did is i associated actually
four items
print and i need key value
key value
key comma value
so what i did is i went through our
built-in
lower all the letters
so lower just so you can see where i got
this from if
if you're new joining us does anything
here
not make a lot of sense all right
awesome i'm glad you like guys are like
in the background hey
uh is the is it very blurry
on your playback because it is very
blurry on mine
if you guys are seeing it good all my
kids are home i was kind of a little
worried about this today
uh is the picture clear for you guys
if it is that's great because like i
said all my kids are here and we're all
streaming
awesome i'm glad i'm glad the color
the darker is good all right okay
not hearing any feedback that it's bad
so i'm gonna keep going
i don't need to see me i'm just looking
over here at the chat okay
so i took and i ran through
okay
all right okay so what i did is
i ran through and i made a dictionary
and i associated a key
so you could flip this around so
basically you could
the reason why i like this exercise is i
want to get you to understand to go
through
because you'll see in a minute what
we're going to do is we're going to
count we're going to count a
if it's if it's in the dictionary we're
going to increment up
if it's not in the dictionary we need to
create it so
we're actually going to look at the
raven
and the poem the poem the raven
from edgar allan poe and we're actually
gonna
count all the letters excuse me
all of the all of the words in the poem
that's what we're getting to
so all right i went through i took
the letter then i associated a
number to it and then incremented up
each letter or i let lynn
the range increment each one so i went
through
and i went through each letter then went
through range so range incremented
through
iterated through my lower and then i let
that count and i let that be
offset by 1 because we know range starts
at zero
now now i'm going to show you how to do
this
where we can zip the dictionary and this
is where it very cool
and if time allows i'll show you how to
do
dictionary comprehension alright so we
don't need
this we comment that out
and we can do this in
three lines right here so
i'm gonna do this a little a little
stretched out so
we could see this i could do this in two
but just so we can
letters equals lower
so just so we can have this together
then num
list list
range 1 through 27
okay so we're off setting 26 letters
all right then key
wrapping this so we're zip we're making
a zip object
so check this out this is so cool
all right so
think about it the thing about a zipper
so you have the the actual zipper then
the two sides and it goes through
and it overlaps i don't even know if i'm
in frame here
so all right it goes through and it zips
each side together
so i have two objects
that are the same length and i zip them
together then i'm telling it
to turn it into a dictionary so i
commented all this out
boom oop letters
and
i'm not spelling anything right today
sorry everybody
and then key boom same thing
so i just wanted to show you how you can
create a dictionary with a zip object
zipping a dictionary there you go all
right so cool we are
almost wrapped up cool we're doing this
in about 10 minutes
all right
oh
is it sporadic for everybody is he
breaking up
because like i was saying that
i was a little worried about the stream
with everybody on at my house
quincy or beau are you guys available
to give me some feedback
is it too is it too bad and too choppy
because
my view is just completely frozen
alright is it present for everybody
okay i just got a yellow and an orange
on my
on my stream i'm clicking over it's
bouncing from red
huh
i'm not getting any response from
anybody okay well i'm just going to keep
going
and we'll go from there until i until i
hear otherwise
so all right now we're going to do
something pretty cool so
i'm just going to put this in and i
actually have the file
you can go out and and pull it down the
raven but i also have it on my github
so you can click over to my channel and
look at that but here's the raven
here's the raven and i'm just going to
put it right here it's a boom
here's the raven the file
don't need to comment that out
now this is how you go about
creating something and you don't know
like i like i alluded to or made a
passing comment about
a dictionary is very powerful uh one of
the tools that i like using it for
is if i have no idea
blurry okay it's going blurry and then
uh
okay it's going blurry and then not
blurry okay well thank you for the
feedback
all right so a dictionary is perfect so
you initialize it
and then if you have a scenario which
you'll run into and i've had plenty
where you don't know how many variables
you're going to have so instead of
thinking of it you have a key be your
unknown you have
an unknown amount of keys so if it's not
in there and i'll show you exactly how
to do it
if that key doesn't exist you create a
new key
for it and then if it does exist you
increment up and this is a perfect
example
so all right
let's look at this and it's literally
this simple
so we take our file
we're going to then split it
so file dot split
so what does that do takes my string
puts it into a list
with each it's going to i'm not passing
it
any delimiter so it's going to split on
the white space
boom step one then i'm going to initiate
my dictionary we're just going to call
this book
helps if you actually then
create a dictionary and dictionaries
live
inside curly brackets
all right then
for
we'll just stick with word word in
file then if
word
not however you want to think about this
but we're going to look at it
if it's not in the dictionary already
we're going to create it we're going to
assign it to a count of one
if word not in book
then book then our key
so it's word
that's our key equals one else
then book word
plus plus
equals one so what i'm doing here
taking this file because it was file
uh variable and i'm splitting it
turning it into a list we're gonna and
then i knit i
initiate my dictionary
iterate through my list looking at each
word
if that word is not in the dictionary
assign it count it one then
if it is in the dictionary then
increment that value up by one so let's
run this
and we have book
holy moly 114 lines
this is what i think is so cool so
here we go so this is every word
counted in the poem
going open a minute
making the code shorter if
would you mind giving open a minute
in this oh um actually what i was
planning on doing
was we were gonna do not just open but
next week we were gonna because i wanted
to entice everybody
we were going to then go and actually
pull this down off the internet with
uh with um url lib and thai
url lib and open together so that's what
i was thinking
i didn't want to deviate too much
because i think we already got
uh but it's a great idea and you can
already
i like i like how you think and that's
why i think we
work well together is that
um i'm going to tie those into
next week next week's lesson so we can
yeah i i try to i try to i'm trying to
do a little bit more foreshadowing uh
but yeah if if we could just stay with
this right now
i'm i i want because open can be a
little
tricky so uh i always try to tie that
with something else
so the open url
well awesome
good and there's also if if there's ever
anything that you guys want
because the reason why we're doing
dictionaries right now is somebody hit
me up on twitter
so look this is y'all's tutorial
so whatever you guys want and i haven't
if i haven't done the complete lesson
plan
i'm more than happy to uh augment
and do what you guys need and want to
see
because i mean i could talk about any of
this
and as you can tell i can get sucked in
to some of it
a little bit too deep so but that's a
great idea
and that's actually where we were going
to go next week i didn't want to tie
these in
and deviate too much especially with bow
being awesome and allowing me to
uh almost do anything so
just wanted to do i thought that that
would wrap
up the dictionary and we might do sorted
i just remembered we didn't do sort here
and i don't have my notes right now but
yes we will we will do that
definitely uh next week then because i
was on the fence about it
so that solves it so thank you guys all
right so where are we
um oh two more
two more questions that came up last
week and then we'll get into this
so we don't need this
so it was formatting we were formatting
the uh our probability
the odds of winning powerball and i
can't remember who
asked but it was um
it was hey what happens if we wanted to
change the format of
of our number so what happens if we
wanted to do
so here let's just look at it
and we do phone phone number
then one two three four five six seven
eight nine zero
so basically it would be you'd hardwire
it in if
it because when i did the placeholder
colon comma python already knows in that
string format
in that formatting uh logic that
it goes and puts that comma after
every third so that was for phone number
that was the example that i had for that
so then literally if you look right here
i have my placeholder
with my string and then i've wrapped
parentheses so in the united
states we typically put parentheses
around our area code
then our prefix then is separated
by the local selection so it's basically
routed to
where in the united states where inside
that where in the united states and then
that number
so now let's look at the
the other one which is basically the
exact same but it's um
it was it was my example for uh here in
the united states and i learned
something cool about
uh australia somebody was asking
how to do the math so may maybe you guys
can confirm but in australia
if i understood they that is the
sequence of when you were born
in the united states our identification
number
our social security number is is built
upon geographic
so the first one is what state then you
have the
group number and then the sequence in
which you apply for it
so and this is more dashes but i just
changed it up so
let's see ssn
one two three four five six seven eight
nine and then
i just go from there but that was uh i
just wanted to
throw that out because somebody made a
comment and you just would need to
hardwire it in
so all right i think that's that so very
cool that only took 21 minutes to clean
up
uh those things and i think there's
another dictionary something
was it or did i get it all
ah one more dictionary comprehension
let's just get it out of the way
so all right we'll look at this and i'll
throw it in here and i promise we'll be
done
so this is this is what's cool about
this so
let's let's look at this so all right
who doesn't like uh list comprehension
i can't remember all right
so basically same idea
here's my for loop so then
now here's my key and value pair all
right
so i have a list of names an iterable
so i'm going to here's my iterable
here's my temporary iter
right no i shouldn't have said that
temporary object iter is something else
so forget i said that here's my loop
then here's my key and value pair so
what i'm doing
is i'm saying i want you to count
a student
i thought it was him i thought it was
him
so uh but you just have to look
look all right you have to do something
over and over
again when you got on a bike you
couldn't ride it right
so i remember when i started doing this
and i couldn't understand
for loops well guess what now i
understand them really really really
well
it's just time and energy and it really
doesn't have to do
anything with how long like how quick
can i you can learn it in 10 years
or five years or two years well it's a
length of time
i like to say it's 10 000 hours you want
to become an expert at something you got
to spend ten thousand hours
and that's it that that's it that that's
the magic number
if you take ten if you stretch it over
ten years okay it takes you ten years
if you can compress it down to five
great takes five years
you want to become an expert at
something you got to spend 10 000 hours
on it
that's that
so what the standard math is it's a
little over it's like 6.7 years
if you do whatever task for 40 hours a
week
that's that's the math so let's just
look at this one more time
here's my key i'm taking my student the
first letter
then i'm turning it then i'm putting an
upper method on it
and then i'm in my value
or my temporary uh so what i'm doing is
i'm saying
how many students have
this first letter so i have
steve i have a john i have an atom
and i have a will so that's that all
right
cool
you weren't stitching that's funny
that's very funny
all right let's get done with that let's
close that
out i don't need that to run don't need
to see that and distract me
but i really hope everybody had a good
week um
last last week was
hectic and busy for me hope everybody
did good so all right
so we need to talk about scope
so i
you're going to hear me use another term
and then
so it's local it's l
what l-e-g-b l-e-g-b
and it goes in the reverse order you
think it will go
so and i got a i got a pretty good
example that i think that'll really help
sell it
it looks locally so inside then it looks
enclosed and closing non-local
so if it's a nested right outside there
that takes next priority
then uh global then built in
so legb
and i'm gonna have we're gonna we're
gonna go through this
really really really really slow so
first i'm gonna handle
uh local global and built-in and then
we're gonna do
uh enclosed and closing uh non-local
those are all the same we're gonna do
that
next to really kind of wrap our head
around it and i think we will have
time to do our monty hall
problem so i'm very excited
all right so i have
well one let's do this so you guys can
see from
math import pie
not super super important but does
everybody know what pi is
the mathematical term the ratio between
uh
circumference and uh radius
everybody everybody anybody that's a old
movie from my
from my time period uh not ben stiller
um but ferris bueller's day off
all right okay good
so as you can see here i have
this variable in three separate
locations
and we are talking about right now
we're talking about uh local
um global
and built in
local global built in
so i'm going to leave all three of these
here and i'm going to show you
so it takes priority from local first
global next well actually non-local next
but i don't want to we're going to do
that in a minute and i'll show you
so we'll put this in parentheses
it's not here global
and then built in and as you can see i
have these
at different lengths so you can see the
uh scientific notation
wow um i cannot think of that term i
thought i was going to be super nerdy so
all right i have all three of them
sitting here
but python will look here first because
this is local
then if i comment this out
then it will look global
significant figures that's what i'm
looking for so i have
because pi built in pi is i think it's
12.
then my local was five then my global
was
two then my uh built in
is 12. so i comment that out then it
will look
then it looked right here so then when i
comment this out
and i run this again then it goes then
it looks globally then it will
see that so the reason why i like doing
it in this order is it shows you
where it assigns and goes with priority
of how it looks so all right
now now let's look
at a nested function
now the nested function is the built in
excuse me
is the building blocks of decorators so
this is going to look
weird and seem weird why would we do
this
well it's a kind of precursor and a
building block
for something else all right let's
comment that
and then we'll use this as a jumping off
point to look at our non-local scope
and in several weeks when we build
a t-kenter calculator you'll really wrap
your head around local orbs
oops okay am i back am i back yet i just
gotta
i just saw that uh obs went down
everybody back up okay
so yes locals are within a function
global variables are
outside and get pulled in and built-ins
are already there
okay awesome yeah i i apologize guys
uh for with all this with everything
going on with school
our uh our kids are delayed going back
and they are all home with me on zoom
meetings so we are eating a bandwidth
like crazy so
um hopefully this will all be resolved
very quickly let me see
what color i am it's red right now but i
think i'm back i haven't gotten a
message
okay i'm back all right
so boom
then def num
then return
exponent exponent in
then return num
so what in the world is going on here
let's see what color we are
or yellow orange hanging around red
yuck all right bounce screen
okay
now it's blurry god all right
i will go slow i need to wonder if i
need to send my kids to
my parents house during during tuesdays
we'll figure that out all right we'll
just go slow today all right
so well that's very cool thank you for
the new supporter
all right
just re just refresh the page all right
all right so what are we doing let's
let's let's look at this
so here's our standard function that
we're used to seeing
we have and we are going to return this
now this is where it gets weird
this function is going to return this
function
all right so this function
my exponent all right exp
sorry my exp function is going to return
my num function so let me give you an
example of what
in the world this will do square
equals xp
2. so
start on the outside build your way in
so now
this is this this is where it gets
a little weird but once you start
thinking about it you'll get
you'll get used to it so i'm taking
i want to create a function that's going
to square something
and this exponent is here
so whatever exponent i pass in
this will be and then now this basically
this is how i want you to think
about it basically just renamed this
right here so function function
this renamed this so whatever i pass in
here
at the end of this object we'll take
that number
and raise this number to the exponent of
this
that's why i called it squaring so now
i'm going to
put this in memory then i'm going to
call square
oops square and i'm going to
i want to square 2. so i get
i get 4. all right so
now i want to make a cube function
cube and i go my x
my exp function and i want to pass in
3. all right
let's put that into memory so then i
want to cube
uh what do i want to do 3 that's 27 3
times 3 times 3
27 haha i remember i remember math
okay now
let's do now let's look at non-local
this is a perfect it's a perfect way to
look at non-local right here
so that was our nested function
okay non-local scope
all right so now what happens if i were
to pass in
a 1 right here and if i wanted to be
able to touch it
from this function because if i say
global
it's going to look outside so there has
to be a way for i just want to move
a variable from just out just
outside not not crazy not globally
it goes right here
so this is how i change the scope of
this i pull this in say non-local
and now so when i pass in
this so what i change this up
whoa square
square three
stays the same because i
overrode this and changed it to one
so i had changed it bend so whenever and
you'll see this
when we do our uh oh i think we're gonna
have plenty of time to do our monty hall
stuff
yes and that is a very very cool
very cool
yes very good i'm sorry
yes the enclosed uh the enclosed so you
have
you have non-local
and closing you're going to hear that
that term
so if you're reading closing that's
typically the documentation and closing
i then also call it so if you heard me
say enclosed
or non-local
all right if i used any of those those
are all the same
this is the this is the technical
definition work you use case in closing
because it is enclosed it's not
it's not it's not local
it's not global it's in closing
so there we go great question this is
why i love the
the interaction because you guys keep me
keep me on task all right so now
now let's look at decorators so we need
to look at decorators
they're very very very very cool they're
a little odd at first
and especially they are
in this case in the these couple of
cases they're going to be weird
you're going to say why but it's to see
the context
uh perfect example that um
i i've used um is to change a function
especially with django so if you for
whenever you're
having a pages and you're building them
you're building a
you're building a function for each uh
page and then you need to lay on top of
it
some functionality and you can lay as
many decorators on as you want to
think about it is because you're going
to see it here and we'll talk about it
a wrapper a wrapping a wrapper function
so it's going to take a function wrap it
in another function
wrapping it around your deck decorative
wrapping you're wrapping up the outside
so that was that's the way i like to
describe the decorators
all right so let's undo this so i can
see
all right so decorator same
same type concept here just the way that
we use it
a little weird all right
so did i need to leave that
no we'll just start over all right
gory tours
so we're going to take a cube
then
all right let's see if we're blurry we
good
all right so we take this decorator
takes in a function
because it's going to sit on top of the
function and you'll see this
so then def i just like to keep this
wrapper
wrapper function so then we've taken an
argument so we can be really clear so we
don't have to think about it
so then we're going to return the
function
and the argument okay funk
and we're going to go real slow because
this can be really weird
and then we return the wrapper
right so this
is this and this
then this returns
this all right let's look at it
so now i'm going to do a def num
x then return
x
num pass in three
all right so let's go through now
my decorator it's going to take a
function
wrap it up take that argument
then do this
to it take this function take its
argument
and do this so when i do this right here
this is all that it takes
so i don't have to create and go out
like we did with our
outer where i'm building my way out
to in this just sits on top
and you still only interact with the
function
that you're changing you're augmenting
you're decorating
you're wrapping it up
all right does that
throw anybody for a big loop because i
remember the first time i saw this
i said what but i'm decorating i'm
augmenting this
to the power of three all right now
here's
one that can be a little bit a little
bit easier
to wrap your head around that works
that works pretty well uh let's see all
right
you got the it's going to be for string
upper so we take in our funk our
function
close that out then we do our then we do
our wrapper
sorry guys i think somebody's coming
home so this
is not going to take any any arguments
right here
so then it's just going to return the
function then
then we're gonna have this right here
wrapper
just like so just like before so we're
taking our function
which is going to be a string because
this is just returning
and if this is a string we know that
that method
works completely so
let's create a death
of hi then return
hi how are you
close that out close that out so we call
hi
i call it hi i think i did yeah hi how
are you so now
on top of this i'm just going to slap
my upper oops
and you you decorate it with the at
symbol
upper and that's it now
later if we're still working together
and we get around to
i don't know i think they already have a
bunch of django but that is a perfect
one
and those are even more sophisticated
those
those decorators because it is a
three three layered here
to take in an argument here to then
redirect but all right
i digress sorry because i know right
here
that this can look a little odd you're
like well why
why would and i get it it's a great
question because i asked the same one
why would you need to do this why
wouldn't you just change it in here
if you have a bunch of functions and
you're going through
and you only want to then augment
specific functions and you're like okay
here i want this one to do this and i
want to do this here
so then we just now now that we have
this called
i got hi and everything's uppercase
or if you need to call one sometimes you
got
you can uh have it call another one but
this this just sits up and and you can
have these
layered i can put more decorators i can
put as many decorators on this as i want
that would work with the type of object
that it is
all right so there we go that is
decorators well awesome this is gone
very quickly so we have we have
a very long time to work on
a perfect example of scope
variables and um the monty hall example
so let's let's go ahead and get after it
so to give you guys a little bit of a
back story of what
the monty hall it was a game show
in the 60s i think and it was a very
interesting concept
so i had heard about it but uh when one
of my kids was
in seventh seventh or eighth grade
they they were doing probability and
statistics
uh probabilities and
ran across this problem so it's if you
have three doors
you pick one of the three doors then
so there's a car behind one of those
three doors
excuse me excuse me there's a car before
behind one of the three doors and
what the where the trick comes in
is the host of the show will
show you a door that is not a winner
and apparently uh they would have
so there'd be a goat behind two of the
doors and a car behind the third one
so what what the trick would be
is he would show you one of the doors
that had a goat
and he would open it up and
what that does to our brains is
it messes with the probability and you
then have the option
is are you going do you want to now that
you know which one
is not the car do you want to change
or do you want to keep the door that you
have
and almost always
the person sticks with their door
and here's the problem and then this was
a perfect
python problem for me to come in and do
for the class because
we ran a simulation and we did this and
were able to prove this
on a huge scale but
if you change doors you have a 66
chance of winning if you stick with the
same door you only have a 33 percent
chance
and i was blown away by it and everybody
right now and i've actually had people
leave comments
in the vid because i have this on my
channel
uh the original time i did it and
people argue about it because it is
contradictory to what we
think and that's why the game show host
did it because most
people didn't change doors so when they
change doors they
they are 66 percent more likely to win
all right so let's get into it
and it's a perfect example because i
remember when i was
because when i was first learning i go
okay and i did this with
um some really really clunky clunky
clunky programming
and then i ran across nested functions
and scope and then so i redid it
so i i don't think i've redone it uh
you'll see the original uh
junkie version if you go back to my
channel but um we're gonna have it here
so
we we're going to go ahead and knock it
out so we're dealing with
um randomness right and then we're also
going to be
moving the doors around so we need to
import
a couple of things from uh from the
random library all right
so from random
import shuffle
and choice all right
so we need to bring this in and look and
see what in the world we're doing
so help on
shuffle all right
shuffle a list in place
what does this mean anybody
we've been going over this couple times
in place return none
means you would need to make a copy if
you want to keep the original
you need to make a copy of it oh that's
actually one thing we need to talk about
at a later class i need to make a note
of that copy
yeah hang on
copy and pointer
hang on pointer
and copy because we need to talk about
this because
you can get hung up on referring to a
place in memory or an exact copy
can be very tricky all right anybody
all right cool all right so shuffle
moves everything around in place will
not be creating a new object
and then choice we need to look at
choice
oops help
so what does this do choose a random
element
from a non-empty sequence so basically
we're gonna have
a uh a list
of two goats and a car and we're gonna
shuffle it
then we're gonna randomly just pick a
an index so our index is going to be our
door numbers so that
that that was the example they brought
out a wall
and it had uh and it had doors on it one
two three
well we have a list uh indexing zero one
two
and we're gonna randomly shuffle uh the
goats and the car
in there then we're gonna randomly pick
one
then we're gonna have the goat from the
list
from the remainder get kicked out and
then
we're either gonna keep the one we have
or
swap for what's left in the list so it's
a
great when i heard when i heard it
brought up if i could uh
if i could program something and teach
the class
it is a awesome programming challenge
so you have to we have to really be
paying attention
so in the nested way we need to do this
we need to create our game right so
our overall function and then inside the
function our two nested
is switch and what do i call it no
switch
and switch so in a scenario
uh we're gonna we're gonna switch ten
thousand times
well the game is gonna take in the
number sorry
um and then uh
and then we're not gonna switch and
we're gonna see and it
is it was very very eye-opening
when i saw this because everybody thinks
and then i finally went and started
looking and
uh was doing some research and it just
shows
why why this show was wildly successful
and why so many people did not win
because it's contradictory to
what what our brains think where you're
like well you just remove one of the
doors
and i'm gonna stick with my door well
you just found out that a third of the
um possibilities have been removed
you need to change doors and you're more
likely to win you're actually twice as
more likely to win
all right okay so we need to deal with
lots of stuff
game then number of
number of times we're going to test this
and then we're going to change
if we're going to change so we're going
to default this to false
all right so now
we have our doors right
i know i'm saying a lot right now any
questions
right now any questions at all
all right cool let's get going
and i think my kids are coming off their
zoom meetings so
hopefully it won't be blurry and it'll
stay good
all right so we got one
goat two goat
car close this out
all right so now we need to shuffle the
doors
because we want this to be random
so then we're going to go how we're
going to do this
anybody got any guesses
i gotcha okay all right so shuffle is in
place
so i want to shuffle these doors so i
don't have to do any assignment right
here
so and let's see
uh pass in take shuffle
pass in our object shuffle
and we pass indoors
so print here
actually we already have all this so uh
shuffle
doors print yeah we'll just do print
doors here
so again uh
right now false okay
all right so now it's shuffled
and it's car goat goat and then we run
this again
go go car let's move this over so we
don't keep getting ate up
so we got car goat goat go goat car
goat cargo goat goat cart goat
all right
okay now oh and we need to track
we don't need that anymore now we need
to track
our wins losses
0 0.
now now what we need to do
get that down there now we need to
create
our nested functions this is where it
gets fun
all right cool so our nested functions
first one is going to be
no switch so right here
so then it needs to know the reason why
the reason why i'm setting up like this
is well one it's
it's it's great practice for uh
to wrap our head around nested then
non-local
and especially since we have two
scenarios inside the game right okay
you can either switch or not switch
absolutely perfect
all right and then things will act
things will act differently so no
switch we don't need it to do anything
but we have we have variables that are
going to be
we're going to be working with right on
local
wins losses because we want to pull
these in
here and manipulate them
if we pick the coat the goat or if we
pick the car
okay and it's literally
now when we get down into the actual
game that
is where this is where it gets fun so no
switch is
we're gonna pick a door if
if the um if the choice is the car
you straight up win if it if you don't
but the fun part
to laying out this logic is for the
switch so if car
equals choice so let's look at choice
again
choice is sequence and then so sequence
is our
interval our list choose a random
element from the non-empty list so we're
going to pass in
choice pass in uh doors
all right and oops
then wins if
if the choice if this choice
is car equal to car
then we're going to increment up one
else losses
because it's if it's not oops
one all right
now here comes the fun part because we
really gotta do some thinking here
oh we may be we're way ahead of schedule
okay i thought all these others would
take a little bit longer
all right
switching doors
switch apps if you spell switch
right and let me check my notes
so now we have our doors
goat
goat and car
then on local because we're bringing in
our wins
losses now
all right so we need to
this is going to get a little a little
complicated so
we're going to pick a door then we're
going to get shown a goat
doesn't matter what what door it's
behind
then in this one we're going to
grab what's left so so let's let's think
about this for a minute
all right
i need a graphical think i have paint
somewhere all right so here
that's not what i wanted where's the
shape
is that okay
all right so i'm going to
pick my door then
then they're going to show me because
there's definitely going to be at least
one goat left because there's two of
them
so then they're going to show me a door
and then
i'm going to switch and pick the other
door
all the time so it's going to be the
last
the last door the only door left alright
let's go through this again
so i'm going to pick a door randomly
choose a door
this is all random randomly choose a
door
the game show host is going to show me
another door
and then i'm going to pick
the last door the the last door that's
left the last object in our list
all right cool is that
does that make sense all right
so let's just get after this
so yeah especially when the math teacher
brought this up
i thought it was well one
i wanted to do the simulation to test
this
because she had explained that they had
done it in class and
proven it well i was like okay well
that's how are you doing that because
she said that they did it by
in recreating
and uh well i was like well i we can do
this with a computer and check this
any number of times and it's
unbelievable how percent well you'll
you'll be able to see
but it just becomes it's like flip it's
like flipping a coin
the more times you flip it the closer it
gets to 50 percent
and your significant figures just go out
and out and out
it's just ah i don't know it's cool
i'm not that good with probabilities but
when it's a concept that i get
i really love it so all right so we're
going to pop out a choice
so range three
so let's go over this why i'm popping
out
why i'm popping out i'm removing
the first random choice pick pick an
index pop it out
boom so now we're down to two so it's at
least going to have one go
right so now now i'm going to remove
a door now i'm going to remove a door
that has we need to look at remove
so we got door right
i just realized that that
all right so we need to look at uh pop
and remove i thought we did that but we
did not who knows pop and remove
yeah i changed thank you i just changed
it to door
thank you um so we put door in memory
and then uh we need to look at der
on door so we have
pop and remove
i realize we did not do
pop remove
sorry wow door
dot pop okay
it will remove and return item
at index whatever we index
or if we leave it blank it defaults
to negative one or the last object
remove well all right you'll be
surprised
um okay the very cool thing about
pop
okay the very cool thing about pop is it
brings it out
and returns so you can grab you do two
things
at one time you go and grab it
and then you can assign it to something
because it pops and returns it
so if you don't put it with some
something assign it to something
it goes away but right now we are
pulling it out of the list we're pulling
it out of the list
then we have our two then we're gonna
have a goat shown
and then we're gonna have something left
here and either
this is going to be the car or a goat
but we're going to take this one every
time
then now no it doesn't put it into
memory
it pulls it and as you're pulling it out
you can assign it to something
but if you don't assign it to something
it goes away so
be very so let's see
am i not because right now my first
choice i just want it gone
what you'll see here in a minute is uh
um we'll do remove and we'll see so
if i wanted to pop it out and
then have it assigned to something
because right now we are just
because because we're switching so i
could have used
um pop out a random choice grab it and
assign it i could
could have done that but right now i
just wanted to pop out and have it go
away
because i'm not using my first choice
i'm gonna go for this one so i'm picking
this
going away don't care what it is because
i know i already know i'm going to
switch
i'm going to i'm going to what's left so
i'm grabbing this throwing it away
going to see a goat because they're
going to show me a goat and then i'm
just going to get the other door
i'm going to pick whatever's left and
if you think about it 66 percent
of the choices are being removed for me
i'm just going to take the last one
that's why this works
all right have i thoroughly
i thoroughly confused everybody so all
right so now
so i took it pulled it out got rid of it
now remove this is what's very cool help
on door
dot remove
removes first occurrence of value so
you're actually passing in
so i got door so i have goat
so if i go door dot
remove
goat
then i go door
so i have goat and goat now we can't see
so it does not remove index it goes
and finds the object that you want to
remove and remove it
so when we pick here at and then we can
so that now i'm going to be down to two
objects
then i'm going to remove a goat because
again
doesn't matter because there's at least
going to be one goat left
there's either going to be after this
after this first choice i'm going to
grab it throw it away
doesn't matter because we already know
where we're switching
all i know is that i'm going to get
whatever's left then there
so either this is going to be a car or a
goat and i'm going to throw it away
and there's always going to be at least
one goat here right
so then they're going to show me a goat
and i'm all in this scenario i'm always
going to get
what's left over i don't care what's
left over i'm going to take what's left
over
and this is how we're going to do it so
second
choice
equals oops equals door
zero then if
second choice
choice equals car
then wins
okay and then
oops
else losses
equals one all right let me pop over
here and see
all right
believe well i thought it was going to
remove a here
doors
all right so as you can see that is not
with remove does it have a default
it would only default it would only
remove first item if that was a
if that was a default value
okay good does that make sense and i
misspelled second
awesome thank you
so does that make sense
and the established spell awesome thank
you
no you guys are great no that was
actually one of the things
if i haven't said this one this
has helped me with my typing because
i've had to be more consistent but two
you have to come up here and you have to
problem solve not only are you
problem-solving and laying out
how to solve the problem but when you
make a mistake like this
you will you will be sent you will be
sent be like look
you're trying real hard i get it but i
got this and this doesn't make any sense
all right so cool so yeah that only that
only
just like this so yeah no whenever you
whenever you're
seeing this and you don't have any equal
signs a default argument
optional argument default optional
basically same thing
okay all right let's keep on moving keep
on checking
so actually we may only get to about 90
minutes today
so now we need to do our
for loop with
uh how many times we're going to do this
because we just we've created our
number of times then if we're going to
change
so then we need to have some logic here
to which which function to run
if change is true or false let's get on
the right layer
so for i in range
x
then let's bring this up let's get rid
of that
uh if change
then switch
switch yuck
and else
and no switch
all right so now we need to lay this out
i'm just going to copy these two because
if i've already been spelling
this much all right
okay all right so let's go through this
i think we can see all of this so i have
my
change so i'm bringing this in
then going through and then down here
as i'm testing how many times are we
doing this
and if change is false
so right so this is either going to be
true or false if it's false we switch
excuse me if it's false we don't switch
see see why i set this to default to
true excuse me to default to false
so if that's true we run
switch we run this we call this function
if we don't switch if that's false
if they don't input to change we come up
here
and run no switch very very standard all
right so
now now let's now let's call this
and run
game 10 000 times
all right all right
wins 33 of the time
and loses 66 percent of the time
so print
and game ten thousand
thousand true
all right
this is where it gets weird this is
where it's so crazy
so if you switch doors you win 66
of the time and you only lose 33
it's it's just absolutely it's
absolutely nuts
and i remember when the first time i did
this i just
i was like there is no way that
that's true and then i went back and i
laid out the logic and
i was like this is absolutely
this is absolutely the truth and how
just very very interesting so actually
you know what we flew through this do we
want to look
at um open
and url lib
because uh we can limp through that's
not
so complicated so i can use my old notes
everybody want to do that
so we can stay on a little bit longer
how's that sound everybody
i can go a little bit more i really
thought that i had
i really thought that all this would
last all right
url okay so cool
let's go ahead and do that then let me
give me a moment or two to dig
up these things because i know i have it
very close
there's the raven stuff url
lib
here i am
i'm in the wrong file
url lib
all right so here we go
we need to let's all right let's comment
all this out
uh check and see because again i i
lose track if url
lib is already in here i know i know
what program i can check and
chord u r l lib all right
i have one program that's not touched
so we're going to be looking at
url lib anybody ever heard of
url lib url lib
and then ooh if we can get through this
and we can do and i don't know another
15 20 minutes that'll get us close to 90
minutes and then
uh i'll make sure we have two hours
because that'd be two weeks in a row
not doing it two hours so i apologize
all right
url lib let's do let's just look at it
help url lib
and this is where it gets odd
packages so now we have to be laser
focused
on what we want to
import
and
ooh and then after this i know what i
forgot to do
we didn't sort the dictionary
that is so cool so we're going to do
that
next because i have a feeling this won't
take that long
so url lib whenever you have things like
this packages
you then need to be laser focused
to bring them in so then you're going to
do
request
as url so now
because i know this can get so confusing
so so odd
so now when i run actually
let's go let's do this real slow
uh help url lib
no i want to do dur on url lib
okay so see it only has
parse sitting in here so then when i go
and do
request
so now i run dir on url lib
so see now i now i have request
and response i know this i know this is
weird
but i don't want to do packages yet
but you begin to see that python helps
you
manage memory so it will only bring in
things that you say hey
i really need this and okay
so request request and response so now
we're
now we're tipping our toe into client
and server so you're going out
requesting then you're getting a
response does that makes
does that does that makes does that make
sense
let me see all right so now i want to
i'm sure you've learned by now and it's
dangerous for me anyway to be typing
all of those letters so we're going to
shorten this to
as url and in case we have anybody new
joining us
i'm sam doing some free code camp
streaming i'm from python basics
every video that i've done here i have
micro videos on my channel
so there's pluses to both of them
a lot right here is a lot more freestyle
and a lot of interaction uh the other
and also a stream of consciousness
where the other is uh micro videos just
uh laser focused one subject at a time
all right so url
and it's request so now we're going to
have so now let's look at
help on url
oops didn't bring this into memory help
you url
holy moly let's run dur
on url
see why you don't bring it all in when
you import url lib
it's ginormous so that is
this is just
we're just going to be touching the tip
of the iceberg with uh where is it
url then url open
um if i knew my alphabet so see
there we are and then we're going to
bring in the file
and then drop it in and then we need to
understand
the text and then we're going to look at
open then we're going to write
and then we're going to go from there so
let's see how we do
let's bring this down here help
url all right we got we know that's a
ton of it yep i want to
i want to expand this and i know it's a
lot
okay url lib request
and it's in the url module and you have
a ton of support and then
here are the classes and then as you can
see
i think there's even more packages
okay but
we're just going to be touching
url open
okay
and i think i have this
i know i have a i put the raven on my
on my github but maybe i'll go
at the top of it and put this file so
you can practice it
let's get this back undone
so
now let's bring this over here so you
pass
in the the address
and the reason why i choose chose the
raven is
because it's um public domain it's
uh it's very very old as you'll see it's
18
18 what 1836 18
and that's actually 1845. so it is
when he he died it's 100 years pass
after the author's death
so all right
oh shoot there we are so now we bring
this
in so we do text
equals page
actually let's not let's go real slow
page oh
aha so now
here's my response object
because it came back like i said you
have your uh
url open because it's um
that's going to take forever endur
on url
it brought in request and response
right and now we have a response
so now we need to read it
and we run der
and look dur if i haven't said this in a
while
dur and help your friends don't don't
try to memorize this stuff because you
will get into
you'll you'll get
url to the raven is the description of
the video
i can't post url
post urls but the video
uh was dictionary uh part two well thank
you very much for doing that
okay well i really appreciate that so
everybody
uh jan is already on top of it uh if
so if you have a hard time coming back
and can't find this
it uh it's it's uh dictionary part two
so all right so cool all right so we're
running
on page
all right here we go so now my page
object
is my response right so my page objects
is a client response
and what can we do with page page
can read
okay so let's let
let's read it so text dot
text equals page dot
read all right so
text
70 lines and what is okay
all right super important right there
right
so help
help on text
ooh it's bites
what can we do with bites let's see
oh oh we can do all kinds of stuff so
there's the help on it
but so we can be laser focused
der on text so we just ran help
oh wow is that text
yep and then here's here's the breakdown
of all the methods
but here's a list of all the methods
methods that we ran so okay so we have
uh we can do all of this and we get it
but we can clean this up just a little
bit
text equals text dot decode
there we go it's just regular
irregular text now so now give me
a second because i need to figure out
where all right 3 8
all right i don't have this so we can
all right so now what we need to do
is now that we've brought this and we
have we still have
i want you to see this you want to be a
good
you want to be a good steward of
connections so
right now we have an open response right
now so we need to close this
we need to make sure we close the page
page.close
you don't want to leave anything open
you want to finish it up
so now page still a response
object but it's closed okay so
now now we're going to create a file
file open
we're just going to name this the raven
dot txt txt
now all right all right
open file name file object built in
function
uh in module input output
now you do not what i just say
you do not have to remember because our
little shopping list
is going to come very handy so all right
r
read there's a default to
mode r defaults to r
defaults to read w
open for writing goes to the first
x creates a new file open it for writing
uh a open writing appending
in the file if file exists binary text
mode
open a disk file for updating this is so
cool
new line mode all right
so there is a lot here
we are opening a file
to write all right and we'll get into
more of this
i don't want to do um especially don't
want to do it
text context editor we're not going to
do a context editor right now because
that can really throw
people for a loop we're just going to
open the file
right to it close it
all right let me get this over here
all right so right now here is
the last order of my files that i have
so we are open we have we have our file
around
it's not what i wanted to see this
let's bring this in so i can
read these okay so all right we open
close brought it in so now we have we
have the all of the data that we want
and sitting in the text text object so
now we're going to create
create a file object we're going to open
it what are we going to name it we're
going to call it the raven
dot txt then we're going to write to it
all right so now i have a file
object file
sorry okay i got a file object what can
i do with my file
object all right
i can read line read lines
seek mode
all right and of course it's right on
the scene
or i can write to it i can read and
write
so whenever you're doing something to
your file
object it has a method read
write so we're going to file
get our file we're going to write to it
and we're just going to what what are we
passing what are we passing to it
our text
now we also want to be a very good
steward
of our connections
and what we have to do with things so
we're opening it we're writing to it
excuse me we're opening our file we're
saying we're going to write
we write to it we close it and we go
from there
all right so that's that whoa look at
this
handy dandy
little thing
we will be i promise you okay since
we're doing this
now let's do our shopping list
uh next week and you'll see how we
handle that
there is a way that you go this then
that
and that and this and that's your little
tease for
for this week to to come back so but no
there there there is and actually if you
read the documentation
it'll tell you i'm not gonna tell you
until next week
so here's our nice little pretty raven
file
god look at that and
we're going to look we need to look at
this
text i want you to look at this format
just laid out just like this
i want you to look does the spaces has
the
end have we talked about this escape
character
in
well i really i really appreciate it i
it's interesting how i've stumbled and
bumbled and stummed across this
stumbled across all of this i love
i love teaching python i'm more of a
teacher than i guess i thought i'd ever
ever uh thought but i absolutely love
so this is here and all kinds of
gobbledygook
but all these nice awesome little rules
sitting right here
and then bam comes out in this perfect
format
and tells text exactly what to do i mean
look at this
it's just it's just right here and it
knows
to do a new line and come through
and just look at it new line a whole new
line
you can just see it right here boom new
line new line
all right now can i believe we didn't do
it so we're done with this
that's open and we'll since we've done
these two
this week we'll do our shopping list
next week
and i'll try to figure out how to make
that sound better than a shopping list
so we get a lot of people who
really can understand um
[Music]
file control and then we're going to
build a context manager uh
that that is it it handles a lot of
things for you it's the width
it's the with uh keyword it's phenomenal
very very powerful all right i just
realized
we did not sort our book so we need to
learn
we need to look and see how to sort our
book that we just did
our dictionary with our book so let's do
that
and then we'll wrap it up so
all right
so let's get our book down here where'd
our book go
all right
copy they won't go back and forth
copy copy and paste
undo this all right so then book
100 and
how many keys are there how are we going
to find out keys
so we do book
lynn book
569 different words
in the raven
569 because there's 569 keys
so that's now that's not the total of
then what do we call it file
so now we're going to do lan on file
so the total poem is 1059
words and there's only 569
different words
so we had a lot repeat so now we're
going to see
how to handle this so we need to create
we need to create a function last
and you'll know why in a second return
return x minus 1
then book now we need to turn this
in and to see all the items
book.items
all right so now we need to sort this
and you'll see why we did uh
why we did items here in a second
because we need the key and the value
right we need to be able to see it we
need to be able to then sort it
and then go from there so now we're
going to do
sorted book
equals sorted didn't want to do this
with lambda we could do this with lambda
but
i know that can be very tricky i need to
do a bunch of lessons on lambda
because uh once you get it you get it
all right the key so first it's book
so it's my key in value then my key
to the sorted is last i want you to sort
it off
and then we're going to reverse it so it
goes it automatically goes from lowest
to highest i want to see
which words in the raven
occurred more the most and then go
backwards
sorry reverse true true
true that's horrible
all right so for i am
sorted
sort book
and oh yeah in this sample i only want
to see
the top 10 top 10 words
in the raven that's what i'm doing here
to print
i zero
and a colon
i guess i didn't feel like putting this
in an f-string format
i wonder how old that is
close that out close that out oops
uh would i miss
i n 10
1 2 print ooh
what didn't i close out
let me see
where's my syntax error i got an error
somewhere
all right we're gonna cheat copy this
paste that
there we go wow looked exactly the same
i wonder what i did did anybody catch
what i did
okay so here we go
so this is the sorted book
sort book so i sorted it i took i
took the file we threw it into
thank you okay all right
so i throw it into my dictionary if the
word doesn't exist i
count the first count at first time if
it does exist i increment it by one
so then i created a my last function
because i'm sorting this
by the last
of the key the value
key value so i'm sorting it by value
don't care what because
what when you sort a dictionary you will
be
sorting by the key so if i just sorted
my dictionary
it would come out in alphabetical order
for my keys
and not caring what my value was so i
have to resort this
off of the key for my items right here
so because i took key and value brought
in
items so book right now is
my key and value pair
how many times did those occur so then i
took
my key in value sorted it went in
reverse
so i went in reverse most so i want you
to sort it by
the value and i wanted to go in reverse
i want it to be
it automatically goes from smallest to
largest i want you to go in reverse i
want you to go from
largest to smallest and then right here
i printed out each
key and value like so and i brought it
in
because my sorted book is
this right here in order
and mike here
and oh shoot
there's a lot in memory that's why this
is acting up sorry guys
so then
the case matters in sorting yes
just bring this back in there we go
and to probably be a little uh
did you see how slow this was so
so it probably wouldn't be hurt wouldn't
hurt to do because i saw it in my notes
here and now that makes sense
so now i have a file object and a book
object so it probably wouldn't hurt to
stop being a memory hog and start
deleting book and file
uh up here especially file probably but
so here we go so the top 10 words are
the and i my of a that
chamber this and at the
or the happen 56 times in the raven
so there we go guys um you guys are
absolutely awesome
uh thanks for coming back and hanging
out
with with me for another uh week want to
appreciate
um quincy and bo for allowing me this
opportunity to connect with you guys
because if there's anything i can help
you guys with and saving you
some pain and time and energy and your
python journey
i want to do it because mine mine has
been
mine has been a bumpy road and uh so
that was the reason why i created the
channel that i did
uh at python basics was what channel
what would i want if
i were starting over what would i
what would i what would i want the
channel to look like
and that was how i started and also did
an experiment uh
put together um if you hadn't seen it
the first
six of my live streams it's five hours
so
now we have you guys have this
everywhere so you can go back and look
at it it's going to be a little bit
different everywhere
mainly the same big chunk but a lot of
like i said a lot of stream of
consciousness so things that
it's like when you hear the audiobook
the the reader the author
might go off on a tangent and explain
what they were thinking and
i've seen that a lot so you get a little
bit more in depth so
don't just do this and think you have it
you've got to practice it just like i
was talking about at the beginning 10
000 hours 10 000 hours however long it
takes doesn't matter how long it takes
just do it sorry guys i've rambled on
enough
thank you guys for um putting up with me
and hanging out with me
i really appreciate it it's very
humbling right now we got 140 something
uh people here like i said very very
humbling
so as always guys thanks for watching
please hit that subscribe button for uh
free code camp if you haven't already
and also that like button so i will see
you guys next week and we will work on
that shopping list so we can really
examine uh context managers and files
i think that's a great idea alright guys
see you guys next week
bye